hey guys I think so as you guys can
probably tell I'm in a different kitchen
today because I'm actually in LA for a
short while while I'm here I figured I
should try and make something for me a
lot of you have been asking about it
she's awesome she's made so many amazing
recipes and she challenged me to make
these really cute see emojis mochi is a
type of rice cake it can be sweet and
savory this is what a normal mochi looks
like it's chewy this one has a sweet
filling a red bean paste filling which
is what we're actually gonna be doing
today
mochi on the outside and then red bean
paste with a strawberry on the inside
and then we're gonna try and shape it
into a cute baby seal it looks
relatively simple to make it's just a
mochi and then you put little arms on it
and then you dot their faces things can
be deceptively simple there's still a
possibility that this could all go very
wrong but as always I'm gonna try my
best and make a cute seal mochi that
really really like yeah so let's give
this a shot I was looking at recipes
online I found out that one of my
favorite youtubers Joon's Kitchen has
actually done this before so I'm basing
my recipe off of his his videos are
amazing I've watched all of them his
cats are adorable so you should go check
his channel out our space is really
simple you only need a couple
ingredients sweet rice flour mochi flour
and then sugar prepackaged red bean
pastes which are also really really good
my mom usually makes the red bean paste
from scratch we just don't have the time
to do that today and then we have potato
starch you can use corn starch just to
keep it from like being sticky of course
there are the strawberry I've bought the
really fancy kind it's for re a has to
be high quality making it fancy as we a
says what does that think she does make
it fancy dude did it did make it make it
mmm this will be the star of today now
let's get started making the mochi first
making the dough is pretty much just
sweet rice flour sugar and water the
mochi flour we need about hundred grams
[Music]
yeah two tablespoons of sugar stir that
together and then now is when we add the
water slowly combine this until it forms
like a paste so hopefully there are no
lumps left here's a little I think that
is well combined so this is kind of the
texture we're looking at what we're
gonna do is to actually pop it in the
microwave for one minute intervals until
it becomes super sticky put plastic wrap
on it and put it in a microwave one
minute now we wait ah okay it's done
this still might need some time I'm just
gonna look at it right now it's not
quite there yet it's in solid clumps
definitely needs more time it is
becoming more solid though which is good
whoo-hoo oh boy okay guys we're getting
that goopy texture now so far so good
put some potato starch onto the cutting
board
well that was cool
cover that up I feel like this might be
too strong
for now it's hot I'm just going to need
this a little bit give it some shape
it's really hot oh this is what I have
so far it's a little bit jiggly which
means it'll taste great but it's a
little too soft right now for me to
shape so let's try that again this is
what we have now
this batch looks slightly more solid I
put a little less water looks like it
can hold a shape that looks like a demo
Chee okay not giant a medium-sized mochi
I think we're on the right track here
I'm gonna set that aside
mochi dough is ready now we're gonna cut
the strawberries and get the red bean
paste ready to go open this oh it smells
so good it's gonna mush this a little
bit cuz it's still in bean form
strawberries I am going to wash these
really quick this box of strawberries is
actually $13 when I said fancy
strawberry isn't meant to so I'm just
gonna cut the top off I'm gonna try and
wrap the whole strawberry in there is
just much more indulgent and if I can't
then we'll half it this is the red bean
paste I'm just trying to crush it make
it more into a paste
right now it's still very vini smush it
kind of like mashed potatoes
don't be like me guys buy the pace don't
buy the beans but if you want an arm
workout this is perfect
that's pasty the red bean paste is now
actually red bean paste so that's good
what I'm gonna do now is roll out the
mochi dough so we can cut them into
little pieces okay can let's roll that
out
oh no it's sticking even know really how
thin it just needs to be big enough to
wrap around the strawberry and the pace
I'm just winging those people I am just
winging this let's just experiment with
one first
no don't stick oh no no it's all
sticking this is a lot trickier and then
I anticipated oh dear all right let's
try that again
guys this piece looks manageable that's
a square I'm gonna get a strawberry wrap
the red bean paste around it surrounding
the shrubbery like that try to put it in
there and wrap it around it
might have been a little too thin you
can definitely see the strawberry on
there red bean and it definitely doesn't
have a pretty shape I don't even know
what this looks like I think what I need
to do is be a little less ambitious so
I'm gonna cut the strawberry in half now
I'll taste it though mmm it tastes good
looks good though from the inside I need
it to look good on the outside too so
let's try that again stretch this out oh
[Music]
there we go so there's one looks a
little bit better how do I make this
into a seal now needs flippers and a
tail trying to squeeze like a little
tail out and then if we get the eyes and
then the nose here maybe I'll just cut
this so that's the tail this is what we
have so far a little bit janky but you
can see the beginnings of it right I'm
gonna give it little baby slippers no
little baby flippers right now wheelies
into little ball shapes make like that
oval shapes like this glue it on like so
stick stick stick stick there we go
flipper one is done now for flipper two
like that I was so worried I'm going to
like completely destroy this it's a
chubby little thing they're trying to
compare the picture we I sent me with
what it looks like right now I know it's
not perfect and definitely use some
improvement but yay once we paint on the
chocolate it should be even better I'm
gonna put this two aside for now make
another one and then we can paint the
faces on
[Music]
we have to write now that was my goal I
have nine minutes before we a comes so
last stretch let's go
can I draw the faces on with melted
chocolate this is the moment of truth
and I hold out for reference I don't
know this is gonna work but ah I'm a
hand shaking oh my goodness my struggle
should I give it I browse oh my God my
hands are super shaky right now
now they're angry seals they're so angry
that I took so long to make
[Music]
how's it look so far I hope it's not
sticking to the cutting board steel
number one it's gonna go here
his heart is poking out that pat-pat-pat
how that look I think having faces
really saved it a little bit I hope it
also tastes okay after a long time I am
finally done took way longer than
expected but I think it looks
presentable I hope she likes it I'm
really nervous right here this kind of
look like blood though but I love it
it's like a boy and a girl you did a
great job let's go I'm tasting
strawberries I was saying how they're
like the fancy strawberries make a fancy
yes we approve i approve you Inga
whether you make it again long pause if
you bring it to pretty people will go
nuts yeah yeah I will not die man that's
great job
[Music]
just to make you fun seeing like put on
a tasty video can I can I do one more
comment below if you want Inga to make
me love baby
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]